♪
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING AND WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
EVER NOTICE HOW SOMETIMES
THE BIGGEST STORIES GET THE
LEAST COVERAGE, SOMETHING
TRANSFORMATIVE HAPPENS THAT
CHANGES EVERYTHING AND
NOBODY NOTICES?
WELL, IT'S HAPPENED HERE.
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS OR
SO, THE REST OF US HAVE
WATCHED AS THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS BEEN UTTERLY
TRANSFORMED INTO SOMETHING
TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
WHAT WAS ONCE THE CENTRAL
HEADQUARTERS THE CENTRAL
LEFT ESTABLISHMENT THE PARTY
OF HARRY REID AND STENY
HOYER AND GUYS LIKE THAT
LOOKS LIKE A SCENE OFF
BURNING MAN.
STARTING ON IMMIGRATION DAY
DEMOCRATS ERUPTED IN PRIMAL
SCREAM AND THEY HAVE NOT YET
STOPPED YELLING.
EVERYTHING CHANGED ONCE
TRUMP GOT ELECTED.
CELEBRITIES THREATENED TO
BAN THIS COUNTRY.
STARTING BEHAVING LIKE
POLITICAL.
POLITICAL CANDIDATES SO
EXTREME THEY REJECTED THEM
MONTHS BEFORE.
NEWS REPORTERS BECAME RIGID
PROPAGANDA.
BEESHEDEST
BEESHED WT
BEESHED WEIRDEST OF ALL
COMEDIANS LOST THEIR SENSE
OF HUMOR.
HERE IS
HERE SS
HERE SAMANTHA BEE LECTURING
AMERICA ABOUT IVANKA TRUMP
LAST NIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW, IVANKA, THAT'S
A BEAUTIFUL PHOTO OF YOU AND
YOUR CHILD.
LET ME JUST SAY ONE MOTHER
TO ANOTHER, DO SOMETHING
ABOUT YOUR DAD'S IMMIGRATION
PRACTICES, YOU FECKLESS
BELIEVE.
HE LISTENS TO YOU.
[CHEERS]
>> PUT ON SOMETHING TIGHT
AND LOW CUT AND TELL YOUR
FATHER TO [BLEEP] STOP IT.
>> Tucker: DUMB PERSON'S
POLITICAL HARANG
MASQUERADING AS COMEDY.
MICHAEL MOORE PROCLAIMED
WHAT YOU JUST SAW BRILLIANT.
HE CALLED SAMANTHA BEE A
TRUTH TELLER.
HE THOUGHT BEE WAS BEING,
QUOTE, GENEROUS.
TONIGHT BEE IS RECEIVING AN
AWARD FROM THE TELEVISION
ACADEMY FOR LEVERAGING THE
DYNAMIC POWER OF TELEVISION
TO INSPIRE SOCIAL CHANGE.
SAMANTHA BELATER APOLOGIZED
THAT ON TWITTER ASSUMING
TWEET APOLOGY.
TEMPORARY.
SHE WILL LIKELY BE BRAGGING
ABOUT THIS AT ANOTHER AWARD
CEREMONY VERY SOON.
MEANWHILE KATHY GRIFFIN THE
SINGLE UNHAPPIEST PERSON IN
THIS COUNTRY USED HER APPEAR
AND ON A DAYTIME SHOW CALLED
"THE VIEW" TO LAUNCH ANOTHER
POLITICAL LECTURE WHEN WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS RESPONDED
TO THAT GRIFFIN WROTE A
PROFANE ATTACK ATTACKING
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH, BLAH F
YOU, BASICALLY.
WHERE DID KATHY GRIFFIN
LEARN TO TALK LIKE THAT?
MAYBE FROM U.S. SENATOR
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND OF NEW
YORK WHO IS NOW REGULARLY
USING THE F WORD IN HER
PUBLIC APPEARANCES.
HERE IS ONE.
>> WHAT ABOUT PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
HAS HE KEPT ANY OF THESE
PROMISES?
NO.
[BLEEP] NO.
[LAUGHTER]
FUNDAMENTALLY, IF WE ARE NOT
HELPING PEOPLE, WE SHOULD GO
[BLEEP] THEM.
>> Tucker: AND SHE IS NOT
THE QUICKEST OF U.S.
SENATORS.
BUT EVEN SO IT SAYS
SOMETHING BROADER ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE LEFT IS ARGUING THAT
TRUMP IS RADICAL.
HOW HAVE THEY RESPONDED?
BY BECOMING WAY MORE RADICAL
BY COMING COMPLETELY OFF THE
EDGE.
THEY SAY TRUMP IS VULGAR.
OKAY.
SO NOW THEY SHUT PROFANITY
ON TELEVISION AND AT
CAMPAIGN EVENTS.
AMAZINGLY, TRUMP HAS SOMEHOW
CONVINCED THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY TO COMPLETELY DESTROY